on en profite ce soir avec toutes ces
annonces avec l'élection qui a provoque
également Guy Leblanc Président
Directeur Général d'Investissement
Québec est avec nous bonsoir monsieur
Leblanc je suis Fillon bonjour je dis à
la prochaine élection parce que c'est au
début du mandat de la coalition à venir
Québec que vous avez été nommé monsieur
fitgiven vous voulez faire vraiment une
transformation avec monsieur Legault
d'Investissement Québec ça fait un peu
plus de 3 ans que vous êtes en place
est-ce que vous diriez que
l'organisation que vous dirigez a changé
radicalement depuis 3 heures
certainement évolué depuis trois ans et
la dernière fois qu'on s'est parlé
depuis ce temps là on a doublé de taille
on était à peu près 500 employés on est
maintenant 1100 employés et en termes
d'intervention on fait quatre fois plus
d'intervention qu'on en faisait à
l'époque parce que maintenant on a non
seulement le financement mais on a aussi
l'accompagnement d'accompagnement
technologique avec Investissement Québec
cric qui s'est joué à nous avec
Québec c'est joué à nous donc maintenant
à l'international on est bidirectionnel
non seulement la traction
d'investissement étrangers mais aussi
l'accompagnement d'exportation parce que
c'était la volonté du gouvernement
d'avoir un mandat justement beaucoup
plus actif beaucoup plus large de la
part d'investissement exactement et
aussi un transfert des employés en
région du ministère d'économie pour
faire d'accompagnement stratégique avec
les entreprises alors la priorité
c'était vraiment d'augmenter la
productivité aussi d'avoir un impact au
niveau des exportations qui est une
priorité du gouvernement et des projets
structurants aussi mais ça se fait pas
sans brasser un peu la cabane il y a
quand même quoi 7 vices présidents qui
ont quitté Investissement Québec depuis
que vous êtes en place comme comment
vous expliquer ces changements-là il y a
des vices présidents qui ont quitté pour
différentes raisons certains ont
simplement décidé de quitter compte tenu
du nouveau mandat ne se sentait pas à
l'aise parce qu'on demande beaucoup plus
cette présence d'un marché on demande
beaucoup plus de d'avoir une des équipes
multidisciplinaires alors si quelqu'un
était plutôt financement pas très à
l'aise dans
l'injection de capital en équité à ce
moment-là ce n'était pas nécessairement
les bonnes personnes qui est en place
pour livrer le mandats qu'on nous a
donné de l'année 202122 a été quand même
bonne là on n'a pas eu le rendement de
l'année précédente qui était de 25% si
je me mettais c'est une ânesse et
exceptionnelle mais ce qu'on nous
demande c'est du vrai rendement moyen
sur trois ans qui dépasse le coup des
fonds du gouvernement qui est à peu près
2% et on est arrivé 7,6%
7,6 l'an passé et 9,3 sur 3 ans sur
trois ans et cette année compte tenu de
l'état des marchés puis compte tenu de
l'économie qui ralentit quels sont vos
projections notre année financière
débute 1er avril vous avez vu pour la
plupart des défends qui ont annoncé
leurs résultats après six mois en date
de juin ce sont des rendements négatifs
alors on fait pas exception à la règle
après trois mois on verra de quelle
façon les marchés vont évoluer au cours
des des est-ce que ça demande un
réajustement de votre part absolument
pas absolument pas parce que notre rôle
c'est vraiment de faire du développement
économique c'est d'augmenter la
productivité des entreprises et
d'ailleurs le Québec si on compare au
Canada puis un Ontario de 2019 à 2021
l'augmentation de productivité au Québec
était de
5,6%, 2,5 au Canada puis 1,5 en Ontario
alors les efforts qu'on a fait dans ce
sens ça fonctionne et ça fonctionne
parce que c'est l'accompagnement et le
financement qui nous permettent
d'assister les entreprises on a une
telle croissance démographique de
population active qui est faible en ce
moment ça prend de la productivité ce
que vous dites c'est qu'on atteint des
objectifs de productivité présente on
atteint des objectifs on a atteint les
objectifs de productivité qu'on s'était
donné pour des premières années du
mandat mais c'est on a encore cette
encore un engin important pour les
entreprises et on va continuer à pousser
dans ce sens-là non seulement avec les
investissements pour augmenter le
productivité mais aussi au niveau de la
main d'oeuvre où on veut jouer un rôle
et on a annoncé d'ailleurs l'arrivée de
miamcy qui va être une vice-présidente
main d'oeuvre et
au niveau de l'international va
s'occuper de mission économique à
l'international pour aller chercher des
emplois
des emplois spécialisés pour des
secteurs clés de notre économie et ça
sera pas nécessaire pour cueillir des
fraises ou des tomates mais davantage
pour d'aller chercher des programmeurs
des pour des pour des secteurs
quand on pense à Investissement Québec
vous avez vos fonds propres c'est à peu
près la moitié ou à peu près le 40% 45%.
et vous avez les mandats du gouvernement
quand Pierre fitzgerbin vous appelle le
ministre de l'Économie est-ce que vous
devez toujours dire oui
ça ne se passe pas comme ça et ça
faisait partie de l'entendre dès le
départ ça se passe comment c'est il y a
ce qu'on fait avec les fonds propres
alors les fonds propres c'est c'est à
peu près l'an passé on a investi 4.9
milliards il y avait 2 milliards en
fonds propres et deux points 9 font le
développement économique alors les fonds
propres c'est 100% Investissement Québec
s'en occupe et si jamais il y a une
transaction d'importance on est vise le
bureau du ministre comme quoi il peut se
faire questionner sur la transaction en
question comme ministre veut par exemple
qu'on investisse dans flying well ou
dans polycor notamment alors vous devez
dire oui non on sait pas qu'on doit dire
oui on est mandataire du gouvernement
avec le fond de développement économique
qu'on gère alors à ce moment-là ce qu'on
fait on fait l'analyse du dossier et on
fait notre recommandation et notre
recommandation est basée strictement sur
des critères de nature économique et non
pas le volet politique ou encore des
intentions du Gouvernement par rapport
donc on peut on peut dire non et on dit
non vous dites non mais la décision
revient au ministre et au Conseil des
ministres selon la taille de
[Musique]
du financement dernier mot sur la
rémunération Investissement Québec il y
a quand même fait la manchette monsieur
Leblanc depuis le début depuis que vous
êtes là les cinq dirigeants les mieux
payés ont touché 4 millions 600 000 ou
31 mars qui est quand même une
augmentation notable et les bonus
versées aux 1090 salariés ont augmenté
de 141% en 2021 pourquoi c'est
nécessaire d'augmenter la rémunération
comme ça écoutez on est en compétition
en termes de talent on est en
compétition avec avec tous les joueurs
institutions financières et font
d'investissement on se doit d'avoir des
rémunérations et on se situe sous la
soudabar nettement on est quelque part
si on exclut des banques par exemple on
n'est pas ça fait pas partie de nos
notre balisage les banques ça va jusqu'à
9 10 millions là pour le PDG là alors on
est on est on n'est pas là mais pas du
tout mais on se doit de d'avoir des
incitatifs pour amener du talent chez
nous et c'est notre mission économique
qui fait en sorte que les gens vont
choisir de venir chez nous avec une
rémunération qui se doit d'être
compétitive jusqu'à un certain point
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle le
discours qu'on entend beaucoup souvent
pour dans ce type d'explication là et
vous maintenez que l'initiative premier
c'est l'argent pour attirer pour attirer
des détails ce que je dis c'est la
mission économique d'Investissement
Québec parce que des gens qui veulent
faire de l'argent pour l'argent vont
aller dans des institutions financières
on a besoin de talent chez
Investissement Québec et on voit ce que
le talent fait en termes de résultats
depuis trois ans merci monsieur Leblanc
c'est un plaisir de vous recevoir merci
d'avoir été avec nous cette prochaine
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]